sur l'île de la réunion dans l'océan
indien le piton de la fournaise est
entré en éruption
contrairement aux volcans de l'arc
antillais par exemple dont l'activité
est liée au mouvement des plaques
tectoniques
le piton de la fournaise est un volcan
by de poids chaud à 2900 kilomètres sous
vos pieds à l'aplomb de la réunion le
noyau terrestre libère une partie de son
énergie sous l'effet de la chaleur un
énorme panache de matières chaudes
remonte à la verticale parvenu en
surface le magma s'accumulent dans une
chambre magmatique et sous l'effet de la
pression il finit par jaillir à
l'extérieur on ne parle plus de magma
mais de l'avs
c'est ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques
jours sur le piton de la fournaise est
depuis la lave s'écoule sur le flanc est
du volcan
allez promis à la prochaine éruption je
vous y emmène avec le monde de jamie une
méga capsule 2d confiné à demain et
n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain